when you think about um the market right
now is there any metrics that you
weren't looking at
three months ago that now you're paying
a lot more attention to i know that
you've got kind of a pretty um uh
thorough process uh just given you know
the the day job but also just your
personal interest but like what is the
metric or two when you wake up you look
at first uh outside of price or
something that would be more elementary
yeah i mean i think it really comes down
to like
i say three or four things um depending
on like how we want to group them like
first of all when i wake up though i'll
just look at price right i mean
really you can look at just scroll
through your twitter you know twitter
feed engage sentiment to see if price
went up or down kind of like joking when
i say that but really you know i'm just
check price see where price is that real
quick if there's a you know really large
moving price
you know i'll kind of work backwards and
say okay well you know bitcoin
absolutely dumped you know was there
some type of bad news that came out um
was it just you know some massive
leverage worked out that maybe i had
been watching out for over the last
couple days and kind of you know
look to see if there's anything
interesting going on there then kind of
just move to you know i have a couple
newsletters i'm subscribed to
um just go through kind of like general
market news just do a quick scroll
through on cnbc see if there's anything
substantial and marketwatch a couple of
these different things and then twitter
like twitter is honestly my main
you know
uh source of information if you will
have likes you know several i'm a very
like not to sound snappy i'm just like
very selective with who i follow because
i like to like go through twitter and
basically have it as kind of like a
bloomberg terminal of sorts where i have
different people i follow for different
specific things um and then you know i
can go through and see all the different
bits of information that i find valuable
from different people that i find
insightful um and then so like i'll say
price
and then you know macro slash news the
other thing is obviously derivatives uh
so i'll use like a coinalize i use class
note a little bit
uh and then i'll go through and kind of
look at you know what's going on with
open interest uh what's going on with
funding um you know spot premiums
discounts uh you know did anything crazy
happen with quarterly's overnight i'll
go and look at order books see if any
you know crazy bids or asks stepped in
and what's going on across the different
exchanges there
and then lastly i'll go through and look
at you know what's going on from a
non-chain perspective but you know
obviously
not a whole lot from a non-chain
perspective because by definition like
we're looking at kind of these broader
trends not a whole lot really changes
day to day you only really need to check
on chain like once a day uh because the
data updates at 8 30 uh est for me
because i'm on the east coast um but it
updates at the same time every day so
you know i'll just sit there on my
computer as soon as it uploads we're
like all right go through check
everything see if anything really
changed for the day
um generally the main stuff that's going
to change if it will is just like you
know
exchange balances obviously like the
liquid supply uh you know the
the
size of different cohorts supply
uh some of those kinds of things but
generally like you know when we're
talking about like these like broader
oscillators or you know some of these
kind of metrics that are
trying to give you you know an edge over
like a several months basis not a whole
lot it's really gonna you know kind of
change day to day but the derivatives
obviously and then and and then the news
uh those those are kind of the two
the two things uh you get their order
books in there too but you know those
are the two things that are really kind
of like changing constantly throughout
the day i would say the other thing too
is like get in a couple really good you
know group chats
because you know i'm like 50 iq so i got
to be in all these group chats with all
these gigabrains to help me kind of get
up to speed right um and so i'm in like
several different
uh
you know group chats with traders or
fund managers et cetera
that you know i kind of just sit back i
try to you know
add some value not just lurk in there
but you know really i'm kind of in there
paying attention asking questions to to
other people smarter than me so i would
say like try to form a group of people
that um you think are you know are smart
and ideally smarter than you
um and you know are you know as excited
about the market as yourself and then
just kind of you know build off each
other i'm like i'm very big on the uh
the whole like stephen covey the the you
know uh
i'm gonna completely bash this but like
the
the the output is bigger than the sum of
the parts right like if you add you know
one plus one plus one it equals five
right because you're combining each you
know individuals uh you know skill set
together and when you have that kind of
synergy between those different parts
especially if you have like you know
several people in a you know telegram or
discord chat that all specialize in
something different when you bring that
together and like the kind of aggregated
output of the you know insight you're
gonna have into the market is much
stronger than any of you are gonna be
able to have you know individually so
those are some of the the things i would
say but you know again the uh
the the group chats and just talking to
smart people has really been the the
biggest thing for me um podcasts
obviously and i keep adding new stuff
but podcasts are in there too but yeah
again like talking to
talking to smart people is like really
the biggest thing man and like just
asking questions you'd be surprised how
many people are like
open-minded i know it's easy for me to
say that because i you know i have a
decent sized following but like you know
really even when i had like you know two
or three thousand followers i would
reach out to all kinds of people and
just be like hey what do you think of
this maybe you get ghosted like eight
out of ten times but you know two out of
ten times is better than zero so you
know just keep asking questions and just
uh stay hungry hey you did you like this
video great we make five of them a day
and post them here on this channel make
sure you subscribe like the video and
see you next time